wandavision is full of references and
jokes that will soar over the heads of
young comics readers and mcu fans
but the adults watching will know what's
what especially if they grew up glued to
their tv sets
here are a few things only adults likely
noticed
in one division the dick van dyke show
is one of the most influential sitcoms
of all time
but kids today likely don't know much
about it considering it debuted way back
in 1961
comedy writer rob and his wife laura
played by tv legends dick van dyke
and mary tyler moore have a chemistry
similar to that of wanda and visions
especially in the disney plus hits first
two episodes
the living room and entryway of one
division's black and white
suburban house is even laid out the same
as robin laura's
with the kitchen on the far right and
the front door on the far left
there's one obvious dick van dyke show
illusion in one division that younger
viewers
likely missed in the faux sitcom's
opening credit sequence
vision carries wanda over the threshold
and nearly trips on a poorly placed
chair
instead he glides right through it
because as a synthazoid
that's something that he can do on the
dick van dyke show
rob typically fell over an ottoman as he
entered the house each week
but sometimes he dodged it by episode 2
of wanda vision
we're firmly in the 1960s and the
connection to the dick van dyke show
is even more clear wanda has dropped her
demure dress
apron and heels in favor of sleek black
capri pants
and more comfortable shoes add her
stylish flip hairdo into the mix
and she looks just like mary tyler moore
as laura another vintage sitcom that
adults are more likely to be familiar
with is bewitched the high concept
sitcom
which ran from 1964 to 1972
concerned a witch named samantha who
married a befuddled guy named darren
i am a witch
well um what makes you say that there
was no way that one division
a sci-fi story told through old tv
comedy tropes in which one of its two
main characters is a witch
wouldn't send up or embrace bewitched
with a point of a finger
wanda changes the for sale sign on a
chosen house into seoul
a very samantha act of instantaneous
magic also like samantha
she uses her amazing powers to
accomplish household tasks
like doing the dishes and making dinner
the latter of which
she accomplishes by manifesting objects
out of thin air
when his boss comes over for dinner
vision virtually transforms
into the hapless darren just as that
character was often left
desperately trying to keep hidden the
fact that his wife was a witch
vision vamps sings and tries other
distraction methods to make sure his
boss and his wife
don't see pots pans and food floating
through the air in the kitchen
in episode three of one division the
action shifts to the early 1970s
more specifically their world turns into
a detailed recreation of one of the most
definitive sitcoms of the era
the brady bunch from the beginning of
the opening sequence
viewers old enough to remember the
adorably cornball comedy about a huge
blended family are bombarded with a
bunch of brady-like bits
back-to-back marshall marsha marsha
the title sequence depicts vision
engaging in mid-century suburban
activities
like grilling burgers and putting
together a swing set and he's doing them
both outside
past a sliding glass door in a tiny
unnaturally well-lit yard
atop fake grass it's a very brady yard
the inside of the house also invites
brady comparisons
such as the double front doors brick and
stone walls
and open platform style stairs
the plot of one division's third episode
revolves around wanda's
sudden unexpected and extremely rapidly
progressing pregnancy
as that occurs in the environment of a
classic sitcom the show embraces and
sends up the many tired cliches
frequently forced it upon pregnant
characters like many sitcom dads to be
before him
vision tries to prepare for the baby's
arrival with logic
and knowledge devouring books on
pregnancy he's a good source of info
for wanda teaching her about things like
breathing exercises to deal with pain
just like other comedy characters who
would attend a lamaze or general
childbirth class
mucus plug
in your face pal in decades past
the big dramatic moment in soaps and
sitcoms that lets the audience know the
birth is imminent is when the mother's
water breaks
and that happens to wanda although wanda
vision subverts the idea it comes in the
form of a torrential indoor rainstorm
the fifth episode of wandavision takes
place in the 80s and the sitcom of that
era it most explicitly emulates
is family ties the smash hit about the
keatons former 60s hippies who moved to
the suburbs to raise their conservative
and superficial 80s kids
this is a travesty this is a sin against
capitalism
one division set in this episode is
dressed to resemble the
keaton's columbus ohio home with the
dark wood flourishes
small stained glass windows and central
yellow couch
vision even rocks stephen keaton's usual
wardrobe of a plaid shirt
tucked into jeans one of the most
memorable elements of family ties for
those old enough to remember
was an opening sequence in which a line
drawing portrait of the keaton's is
slowly filled in with paint
one division's credit sequence recreates
that albeit with an
independently moving magic wand-like
brush doing the painting
family portrait painting aside the
opening sequence of the 80s sitcom style
episode of
wandavision is all about another hit
show from that period
growing pains that show abc's answer to
nbc's the cosby show
is also about a wealthy huntington long
island family
in which the father is a doctor older
wanda vision viewers will remember
growing pain's opening credit sequence
which the mcu show recreates while
lovingly poking fun at the whole thing
set to a theme song like the one from
growing pains with mockish
and overly sentimental lyrics about
family and love
sung over bright electric guitar riffs
the visuals consist of photos of wanda
vision and the family growing up just
like it's 80s sitcom inspiration
growing pain's visual style makes one
more appearance toward the end of the
episode
wanda not wanting to listen to vision
confront her about her cruel
manipulation of time
space and lives makes her tv life's
credits roll
and they're in the same typeface as
those from growing pains
in wanda's concocted sitcom world of
westview
much of the mystery focuses on her twin
sons tommy and
billy the twins exist in the comics but
on one division
especially during episode 5 they're a
vehicle to send up the presentation of
children
in 80s tv comedies at the beginning of
the fifth installment of the series
tommy and billy are infants by the
middle they're kindergarten age
and they're 10 years old by the time the
episode concludes
their rapid growth is both a function of
wanda's magic
and reflective of how sitcoms in the 80s
routinely did this
for example andrew keaton on family ties
and
chrissy seaver on growing pains both
went from baby to wisecracking grade
schooler in just a few months
and their rapid aging was never
acknowledged
speaking of twins the most popular 80s
sitcom
involving identical children is
definitely full house
episode 5 of one division includes a few
references to that family-friendly hit
when anybody does anything sentimental
or cute on one division
the studio audience emits a trickly ah
for example
and toddler age tommy and billy are
reminiscent of nikki and alex
uncle jessie and aunt becky's tiny twins
in the opening credit sequence wanda
vision and their kids
run through the rolling fields in the
town square toward the camera
and end the sequence with a picnic
captured in a wide shot
both of those moments are instantly
recognizable to viewers of a certain age
as straight out of the full house
opening this is all amusing on another
level too
michelle tanner on full house was
portrayed by twins mary kate
and ashley olsen the older sisters of
elizabeth olsen who stars as wanda
on one division by episode six of wanda
vision
wanda maximoff is still living in a
television-based alternate world
of her own creation which evolves each
week to correspond to an increasingly
recent
real-life sitcom in this installment the
show moves from the 80s
and early 90s tropes of family ties and
growing pains to get to the edgier
rougher single camera laugh track free
comedies of the 2000s
particularly malcolm in the middle the
beginning of one division's
sixth episode is packed with references
to the fox hit
which debuted in january of 2000 a bit
before younger viewers time
the opening sequence of the older show
featured harried mom lois caught in a
towel
and one division's intro segment also
shot phonetically and with lots of video
feedback and footage discoloration
finds wanda brushing her teeth not
thrilled about getting captured on a
camcorder
character names presented as credits
appear in a similar font as the one
utilized on malcolm
then once the action of the show starts
billy and tommy break the fourth wall
and address the audience directly
a device employed by malcolm throughout
that series run
jaunty ska flavored music plays lightly
on the soundtrack as they do
a nod to malcolm's similar score one
division also emulates malcolm's visual
style here
employing the use of quick wipe cuts and
odd camera angles
because wandavision is a sitcom or at
least a show set in an artificial
sitcom-derived world it gets a halloween
episode
the mcu series sixth installment finds
wanda
vision the twins and pietro celebrating
the big fall holiday
and they dress up for the occasion in
form-fitting brightly colored halloween
costumes
their outfits are too cheap cheesy and
flashy to not be designed
to catch older viewers attention and to
make them search their brains as to why
those outfits
seem so familiar the reason is also an
in-joke for marvel comics fans
wanda aka scarlet witch and vision
mostly hiding their superhero identities
don't often appear on wandavision in
anything like a superhero
costume but on halloween they dress up
in recreations of the superhero costumes
they wore in marvel comics adventures
published long ago in print wanda wore a
pointy headpiece
cape and leotard just like she does here
while vision's green bodysuit and yellow
cape
is also comics appropriate even pietro
gets in on the fun
donning a blue t-shirt with a silver
stripe and hair fluffed upward
resembling the inked version of his
super alter ego
quicksilver the term breaking the fourth
wall
refers to when an actor addresses
viewers directly dissolving the
invisible barrier between worlds
it can also be used to describe that
thing in 21st century mockumentary
sitcoms where characters appear in
confessional segments to explain their
thoughts and actions
or turns to the camera to react to the
behavior of
others those are all tropes of modern
family and
the seventh episode of one division
breaking the fourth wall
is full of homages to the emmy-winning
abc smash
wanda is starting to crack under the
pressure of maintaining a faux sitcom
world
and she decides to grab some me time all
of which
she discusses by talking right to the
camera which fidgets ever so slightly
and jaggedly zooms in on her face every
so often to mimic the handheld style of
modern family
her talking head segment is delivered
from a striped chair that one division
producers
seemingly took right off the set of
modern family which also inspired this
episode's look
with its chic interior design and
expensive looking furniture
the jazzy big band drums on the
soundtrack also remind older viewers of
that popular sitcom as do vision and
agnes
silently expressing alarm over wanda's
actions for the benefit of the viewer
the opening credit sequence borrows
modern families typeface at the end
but this style with rapid-fire examples
of wanda
appearing on real-life objects comes
straight from happy endings
a sitcom that once came on right after
modern family
it also brings to mind the us version of
the office
another famous fourth wall breaker with
the iheart wanda mug
and the similar theme song check out one
of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about
wandavision are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]